hot breath and uh bob jorgensen
asks can you tell us about your editing
process
how do you decide when a joke is edited
properly um
well i don't the thing is sometimes
as i was uh earlier i've i'll do a bit
and then i try to tag it over and over
or keep adding to it on stage and then
and then you will do it so much that you
can tell that the audience has lost
interest or you lost them and then
that's how i was like okay
i'll stop it there or sometimes i'll if
i start going too dirty and i feel like
i'm getting groans i'm like okay well
that's not what i'm going for
i'll i'll tone it down a bit or take out
a line because i feel like that's
um too much but
um i usually i don't really edit i
usually just try to keep adding on
i always joke i write a premise i'll
write a joke and then i tag it three
years later because that can happen too
[Laughter]
you bring you're like oh i haven't done
this joke in a while you do it on stage
and then all of a sudden because you
haven't done it for a while you thought
of a new thing about it and then you're
like wow
i just added to it now it's a new joke
again
and will you when it comes to editing
will you like record your set and then
like review it are you disciplined in
that practice
i try i'll listen to a set
i like i the reason why i record a set
is because sometimes you'll have this
happen you'll have a joke that's working
really really well
on a consistent basis for a while and
then all of a sudden
out of the blue it stopped working
so then i have to go back and listen to
when it was working
and figure out what i was doing
differently
to what i'm doing now
every now and then it's because you
dropped a phrase you just i naturally
drop stuff
and it's not because i do it on purpose
it just
happens you forget about it
and then that's why you got to listen
you got to go back and listen
yes the the work that people don't see
in comedy is that like writing
recording reviewing performing it's just
like people just think sometimes it's
just a magic trick
yeah no you're like yeah you're
constantly
i mean i'm always working on the wordage
on stage
i'm like okay that wasn't like i have a
bit right now about throwing and it's
not on my album
but it bothers me that it'll work
sometimes and it doesn't work now
or all the time about the idea of
throwing trash into space and so i
always and like every time i try it i
always try to different
angles with it or pair it with another
bit or maybe use it as a
like an emphasis for another joke or
something